hello everybody and welcome to a brand
new video today I'm going to be starting
off a little miniseries uh for free to
play because I've been enjoying flipping
in freet to play so much I decided to
make a little series about it I'm going
to see how long it takes me to go from
50 mil to 100 Mil and now I'm going to
be flipping only the highest end items
in freeto play uh which recently have
been having really good margins on it so
we're going to start with 50 mil uh flip
only like gilded uh trimmed armor uh
hell giant Club some of the more
expensive items and play and see how
long it takes me to get to 100 Mil
considering I got like 6 or 7 mil profit
in one episode uh I don't think it'll
take too long so I hope you guys are
stoked for the series and let's get
started all right guys so we have 50 mil
to start with um we're going to not be
uh limited to three offer slots because
uh while I know I'm not totally legit Al
going to be doing is reducing my
progress by 50% and if you wanted to you
could have multiple free playay accounts
to get around this anyway uh so we're
going to keep this all localized onto
one and then we don't have to make our
progress take so much longer so we're
going to start off with the monk robe
top G uh as you may have seen in my
other flipping video very expensive item
but can have a really nice margin on it
uh so we're going to buy it for about
6.1 mil and go for four of those which
will be about half of our cash uh but
again sometimes have 2 or 300K margin
even 600k in my last video so pretty
good next up I want to try the Gilded
chain body which looks actually really
promising almost has a 100k
margin on it right now and um we might
be able to even buy 10 or even 20 of
these CU I definitely buy and sell a lot
quicker and um if you buy 10 it'll be
about 1 mil profit so pretty decent
going to put an offer in for about
658k and um we'll go for 20 maybe it
might be a little ambitious though and
last up is the team Cape zero now I'm
kind of banking on it rising up a bit
more
3745 is um it's quite a bit lower than
it's been in the last uh day or two so
we buy it for um about 307 we'll put it
in for maybe 3780 or something and it
rises up to 4 mil or even more uh that
will be a nice 3 or 400k profit uh so I
think it's worth in kind of minor risk
so we're going to put in for 37
81k and we'll just use the rest of her
money so we'll try for three and um yeah
guys we'll come back when uh these items
have sold all right so most of the items
have sold off um the guilded chain body
we got a 100K margin and we managed to
get nine of them five of them have sold
so far so on the Guild of chain bodies
we got 550k in profit so far and the
team Cape we got a
398k margin so pretty good almost 1 mil
in Profit just from those two items plus
we have another four chain bodies we're
selling off right now so now I think the
plan is to just load up the GE with
items so we're going to start off with
this gilded plate skirt uh looks like it
has a 50k margin on it which is really
good and I think it'll trade a similar
amount to the Gilded chain body uh which
we accidentally searched up all right so
hopefully we can buy the guilded chain
skirt chain skirts for about
321k and um maybe pop them in for 370k
after they bought we'll go for 10 of
them uh next up an interesting item is
actually the sadom and full Helm now
this item trades pretty frequently like
probably 10 or 15 an hour or something
um well maybe not quite that much but a
lot more than the other items and it
looks like I could get a 10 or 15 GP
margin GP 15K margin on it uh and uh if
we bought like the full buying limits
worth which I would assume is maybe
around 70k or 70 my God I can't say
anything right uh but 70 might be a
little ambitious but uh still it's a
good margin so we'll probably try for 70
and just see how many we manage to buy
uh another promising item is actually
the Gilded full Helm looks like it has
about a 70k margin on it and uh trades a
similar amount to the rest of the
guilded items so I mean even if we
spread our money through all these items
eventually we're going to find something
that actually works pretty well so we'll
do 10 guilded full Helms about 592 uh
next up we're probably going to try the
Gilded chain skirt or chain body again
uh cuz it just had such a good margin on
it and it looks like the low price could
still be around 6 660 or so uh so we'll
try uh buying them maybe for
666k uh just to curse ourselves a little
bit and we'll go for another five or so
uh another item I've tried a couple
times is the team Cape X looks like it's
is actually at a pretty decent low price
right now at about 1.6 mil even uh so I
think it could very reasonably raise
back up to 1750 in the next couple hours
so we'll see if we can snipe a couple at
this price uh now looks like 1.6 and uh
we sell them for 17.5 hopefully or 1750
anyway and yeah we'll try for 1606 and
we'll go for maybe three or four yeah
we'll go for five five even and to find
one more item uh another decent item
that I do a lot is the hill Giant Club
um probably 70 or 80k margin on it is
pretty common and uh trades quite
frequently compared to the other kind of
rare items I'm doing uh so we'll try it
for maybe 1211 and go for 10 would be
kind of realistic U but yeah looks like
I still get a 50 60 maybe even 70k
margin on each club which would be
pretty nice and finally we're going to
try maybe the monks robe top G again uh
has a pretty big swing in its price you
can see almost a 700 800k swing uh so
we'll try just to see if we can snipe it
for its low price uh cuz that would be
very good good amount of profit if we
could buy it for about 6,400 sell it for
7 mil uh but yeah we'll just try for one
and uh come back when these items have
all bought all right guys so we have
most of the offers coming through uh the
guilded plate skirt coming in first I
got about eight of them so far buying
them for 321 uh so we're going to check
on G tracker what we can sell them for
now I don't always recommend using G
tracker if you're using uh flipping high
volume items you might as well just
check them yourself self uh but for
items like this where they're not traded
very much they're kind of Niche items uh
GT tracker has very accurate prices for
that because in half an hour there may
only be a couple actually sold uh so we
may actually get the accurate sell price
uh so we bought them for um 321 and
hopefully we can sell them for 400k
would be really nice not sure if we're
going to get that or not uh but yeah
we'll pop them in maybe for summer
around 3 uh 390 or 3400 exactly or
something like that uh we'll go for 380
9 and uh yeah they'll be about 7 or 800k
on those pretty nice uh we did get a
team Cape zero as well I can't remember
the price for that uh but looks like we
can sell it for about 4.1 mil maybe uh
not quite 4.1 mil maybe 4.45 or
something like that uh yeah 4054 five
and uh we'll check the margin after we
sell that because I think it's going to
be pretty decent next up is the Gilded
chain body you can see our Buy price at
the bottom there for it was 666 and but
looks like we can actually sell it for
768 which is still retaining about a
100K margin on the guilded Chain bodies
uh which is really nice that would be
Fork profit uh we might keep that offer
in there just because of how lucrative
these chain bodies are ending up being
uh yeah we'll probably just leave that
buy offer in now on to the hill giant
Club okay so we bought them for 1221 and
hopefully we can sell them for it be
kind of nice to sell them for closer to
1,300 would actually get us a decent
margin so we might leave those in for a
higher price cuz we are going to go to
sleep pretty soon and U maybe little
sell overnight as yeah maybe 1319 might
be reasonable and uh would leave us with
a pretty nice margin on Hill giant clubs
next up we're probably going to sell the
the uh Team Cape x uh which looks
actually pretty high up so 1778 looks
like the one of the last recorded prices
and we bought them for 1606 and that'll
be 150k maybe a little bit more even and
we have two capes to sell so it be a
300K profit we'll probably just pull the
offer out and sell it then uh cuz we
probably don't have the proper price
anymore cuz these buy a little quicker
than just two every 8 hours uh so we'll
try for
1777 and uh that'll leave us with a nice
300K profit okay so we sold pretty much
everything guys uh the sadom and full
Helms will start with we got 12K in each
and we got eight of those giving us 96k
in profit I can see right there uh next
up uh the team Cape zero uh we sold one
of them for a
178k profit pretty decent on that as
well the Gilded chain body we got 101k
on each one now we have I think nine or
10 of them and we've sold four of them
so far for a 404k profit so pretty nice
um the iron gold trimmed is another item
I decided just to toss in there we
bought him for one7 and sold them for a
90k margin giving us 270k on that the
MVP for this is actually the hill giant
club uh coming in at 108 K margin on
each one uh we're selling nine in total
so once those are all sold it'll be
972k in profit so really close to a mill
very good on that item and the team cap
X's as well got 171k on those and we got
two of those giving us 342k in profit in
total we're probably getting close to
1.5 1.6 mil in profit off of these flips
so really nice and pretty excited to try
some of these items again so to start
off we're going to put another offer in
for the Gilded chain body been coming in
with consistent 100K flips uh for 666 so
it's a little luckier than I thought so
we'll do another 15 of those uh so one
item that I would did try kind of in the
background was the iron gold trim Set uh
which it looks like right now is a 90k
margin on and they do trade pretty
consistently so if we can actually find
the item iron no uh we'll find it
eventually but it looks like it has a
100K margin and we only bought three of
them last time because it looks like the
price changed pretty quickly the iron
trimmed set LG uh no it's the iron gold
trimmed there we go and I think we can
buy them for about 1 mil uh one yeah
1010 and sell them for about
1099 uh so I'll try buying 10 of these
and hopefully we can actually get all 10
this time next up looks like the team
Cape zero is swinging in price quite a
lot so hopefully we can buy it for the
low price of about uh 3,800 or 3900 or
so and uh maybe sell it for even 4.4 mil
that would be pretty nice not sure about
that so but we'll definitely we have to
give it a try at least so maybe buy it
for about uh
3950 uh let's see here 3940 and uh we'll
go for a couple of these team capes um
but we'll save uh eh now let's use all
our money on this and we'll come back
when some of these items have
sold all right guys we are back and uh
we have sold pretty much everything off
the Gilded plate skirts we did finally
sell and we've got a 58k margin on those
uh8 will give us about 500 44k so very
happy with that especially for the price
that's really good the iron gold trim
Set uh is a 86k margin and six of those
gives us
516k uh so between the two that's over 1
mil in profit so really good for the
items especially and the hill giant
clubs we did sell off as well uh if you
recall it's about a 1 mil profit on
those so pretty nice all right so the
first item we're going to do is the
monks robe G you can see it's actually
quite cheaper than it has been in the
last week or so uh so I think we're
going to put two offers in one for the
high price and one for the low price
uh the high price being about 2030 would
still net us about 200k and the low
price being about 18875 would give us
about 3 or 400k on each one uh more than
likely we'll just buy it for this price
but still that's pretty decent and yeah
yeah we'll put another offer in for
about 1875 and maybe go for three of
these not sure if we're actually going
to buy these or not but we're going to
be gone for a while so there's a chance
at least next up here you can see
actually the Rune armor set LG which is
a pretty highly traded item actually has
a really uh sporadic margin the last
couple hours and that's probably y
tracker picked up on it uh but it looks
like we could actually get a 10 or 15K
margin on it once we switch worlds at
least so what we're going to do is
because the item is going to trade a lot
we can expect to buy it quite a few
we're just going to manually check the
margin so we bought it for 159 and we're
selling it for 146 uh which is pretty
decent so we're definitely going to go
ahead and buy some of these try 146 500
or so and um now G tracker says the
limit is 30 but we'll test that a bit
and maybe go for 50 and yeah looks
pretty promising all right so I think
we're going to try this golden chef's
hat I never tried flipping it before but
uh I don't know it's another kind of
rare item so we'll give it a shot buy it
for 577k and maybe get a 50k margin in
each one we'll see and we're going to
try the team Cape X again uh try it for
that's about 666 again ooh not that much
uh 16 68k and we'll just try for three
or four of these looks like it has a 100
200k margin so not bad and last up we're
going to try the monks robe top again it
looks like it's gotten way more
expensive the last week or two but still
looks like it could have a really good
margin on it so we'll try buying it for
about 7 mil exactly around there it's
risen up almost 600 700k in the last
couple weeks I wonder if that's because
of my video I don't know uh but we'll
try for two of these and leaves us with
6 mil I think that's all we're going to
do for now all right guys so the final
flips have come in and I think this is
where we're going to end the episode for
today uh let's go over our last items
and see how much we actually made in the
entire episode uh so the monks robe G we
sold for a uh 69 9k margin four of those
gives us 276k in total so pretty good uh
the Rune armor sets were a little bit
messy we sold them at two different
prices but in total we got 317k so
pretty good uh the team Cape X's we got
79k on each and three of those gives us
237k the uh monks robe top G we got 150k
on each not as much as we were hoping
but still a 300K profit overall uh the
golden chef's hat we didn't get very
much on only about 60k in total 15K on
each Mar
and um we have these guilded chain
bodies now the price has changed a bit
they're selling about for 600k right now
but look at this we actually managed to
snipe one overnight for about
366k uh so we're just going to pull
those out for now and um I think they
should sell still for about 699k it's
just a kind of temporary dip so we're
going to be gone for a while so
hopefully we can sell these uh while
we're gone so hopefully 700k should be
good uh so we take 2796 is what's left
in our items and add it to our current
cash stack total let's see how much we
actually made uh in today's episode so
53 628 plus 27 96 is going to leave us
with 56.4 mil so 6.4 mil in profit I'm
really happy with that we're well on our
way to getting to 100 Mil already uh
pretty good for an episode and actually
free-to-play flipping has been better to
me than payto pay flipping recently and
I hope you guys are enjoying the free
playay content if you are please leave a
comment or like and uh I will see you
guys in the next episode
[Music]